all right so for the daily wire the
White House Press briefing room erupted
on Monday after a reporter from an
Africa focused Outlet accused press
secretary Karine I'm sorry Karen Jean
pair I can't believe I almost said it
correctly of making a mockery of the
First Amendment Gene payer stepped to
the briefing room Podium followed by the
cast of the Apple TV series Ted lasso
who was visiting the White House to meet
with President Joe Biden about mental
health awareness soon after taking the
stage Gene Perry was pelted with
accusations of discrimination from today
news Africa correspondent Simon um
attiba
Jean pair uh Gene pair tried to hush the
reporter saying we're not doing this you
told him repeatedly but he kept pressing
I think we have that footage let's watch
that
yeah right you're right you're here for
me right for me no no no no no no that's
not we're not doing this we're not doing
this we're not doing this we're not
doing this
evening
against some people in the Britain world
and I'm saying that this is
China Russia
okay
it's been seven months
welcome guys welcome welcome to the
Press briefing room okay
sure let it go
are you ready are we gonna behave
while many folks
please
all right so he's a parent I guess he's
upset that he hasn't been uh I don't
know all the
way okay we could stop I don't know all
the details behind his particular gripe
but apparently from what I could tell
he's upset that he hasn't been called on
in seven months which seems fair to me I
mean you've been sitting there for seven
months and they won't ask you a question
uh
so I'm on his side
I'm well I'm automatically on his side
because he's uh because he's annoying
Karen Jean pair so automatically I
sympathize with him no matter what his
gripe is
um and I especially sympathize because
this uh White House is a total joke and
a farce and an embarrassment to us all
and which is evidenced by that image of
uh you know the White House Press
briefing and the cast of Ted lasso is
standing in the background
and a white with everything going on in
the world
that even this white house I mean they
tell us all the time we're facing uh a
crisis from all these different
directions the world's about to end
because of climate change Russia is on
the verge of taking over the world I
mean this is what they tell us
and you have time
to bring in the cast of Ted lasso at the
White House
and they're there to advocate for mental
health why would
why are they experts on mental what
because they make a TV show they make a
feel-good TV show
and so that makes them experts on Mental
Health
I mean these are the people they're all
about credentialism usually there it is
the the image
so usually it's all it's uh all we have
here is credentialism from the laughter
from Democrats well what are your
credentials where did you go to school
to become an expert in this and then
they turned to the cast of Ted lasso
to be mental health experts at the White
House
I tell you something uh to these guys if
if you want
for one thing if you want to help
everyone's mental health then make a
better TV show how about that
okay your TV show is so that that hurts
my mental health I tried to watch Ted
lasso and it deeply damaged my mental
health because the show was terrible and
it was and it was made even worse
because it made me lose faith in
humanity just a little bit more
because all these people were saying you
got to watch Ted lasso it's a great it's
amazing it's an incredible show it
wasn't just like oh it's mildly amusing
people said it was incredible it's a
great show and so I sat down with my
wife and I said let's is everyone saying
it's a great show including people that
I used to trust and respect we sat down
to watch it and it was like kind of
charming for maybe
a total of about 47 minutes of run time
and then from then on out it was it was
terrible and I'm watching it and I we
actually watched
um
I I didn't watch every episode but I saw
enough because I I'm sitting there like
almost like
in slack jawed amazement
it's like this is Everyone likes this
show this is awful
it's just it's trite it's syrupy corny
like over the top and then and then and
then also you get into it's like it's
the the character motivations don't make
any sense it's one of those shows where
they here's what happened with the show
they have uh they had an idea for a skit
but it's like like a kind of amusing
skit
um which would have been it would have
been a good skit for four and a half
minutes but now they're trying to
stretch it into multiple seasons of a
series and they ran out of material very
quickly and uh that's how you end up
with one of these shows where the um
you know some of the characters they
their personalities change out of
nowhere it's not even character
development where there are gradual
changes but just like out of nowhere
they become the opposite of what they
were in the last episode because they
the writers just need the characters to
do whatever is needed in this particular
moment to get through the episode
um and they need the characters to
assume whatever motivation works for
this particular plot line there isn't
it's not necessarily cohesive with the
whole so it's one of those shows anyway
just a really a a bad show and uh it
hurt my own my mental health suffered
because of it
and so if I was in that White House
Press briefing room I would want to hold
them accountable for that that'll do it
for this portion of shows we move over
to the members block hope to see you
there and uh if you want to join us
there you can become a member and by
using Code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]